hello everyone and all aboard today's
episode that will feature a
scintillating cinematic shark showdown
that will prove once and for all
which carcanon based film is the
greatest of them all
since the dawn of time for 1975
moviegoers have been thrilled chilled
and kept out of the water by
fearsome feature films that depict the
majestic thin the many rows of teeth and
of course
the eyes lifeless eyes like a doll's
eyes
not in competition in today's show is
jaws
two or three the original is not
what do we even oh i gotcha okay
you see folks jaws is taking the day off
because let's be honest
it would not only win every category in
today's versus episode eliminating all
the suspense that that movie is so good
at generating
but jaws could also easily cruise to a
win in shows like
best buddy movie best boat movie best
spielberg movie best 1970s movie best
movie score
and best movie in which a lead character
eats a license plate
jaws is one of my favorite movies of all
time featuring one of my favorite movie
mayors ever
and to paraphrase the great larry versus
is a summer show
we need summer dollars the beaches will
be open this weekend for
a shark silver metal showdown competing
for the title of
second best shark flick ever will be
deep lucy the shallows
and the meg the genetically enhanced
swimmers are battling a shark with a
vendetta against
gossip girl and tangling with an ancient
beast not seen since before jason
statham met guy richie
pretty solid competition for second foot
wait no draws the revenge
come on that shark swam all the way down
to the bahamas just to rain on michael
caine's parade
this episode is officially under protest
but i'm told we're short on time we
gotta move here so we might as well tell
you
how we'll determine a winner round one
box office
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
round three iconic moments round four oh
the humanity
and then we'll do a wild card round that
i kid you not
might be who has the best fin vanity
shots sharks are like the cool cars of
the sea and the fin is their spinny
hubcaps that the kids love so much
with apologies to open water and 47
meters down
today we will definitively decipher
which shark movie can walk into any bar
in the world and say
i'm the best there is besides
jaws smile usobs and rev up your bigger
boat because it's time to get it on
i'm gonna make this thing bleed 45 foot
shark
you hit me nice
[ __ ] it could have been worse i could
have let him eat chess round one
box office although it's not in the
field of competition today due to the
illegal killing of a sweet doggie named
pippin
when jaws was released in 1975 movie
studios the world over saw a dollar sign
potential with sharks
those movies can take butts out of the
ocean and plunk them into movie theaters
like few creature features can
and our three movies vying for the
silver medal prove it the shallows deep
blue sea and the meg
can all boast over a hundred million
dollars raked in each at the worldwide
box office
in fact the shallows is the only one of
our movies that failed to garner at
least 100 million dollars at the
domestic box office
grossing 58 million bucks here in the
states however
it does remain competitive simply from a
return on investment standpoint
as the budget for that movie is by far
the lowest clocking in at around 20
million dollars
given the fact that the film would go on
to earn 118 million dollars worldwide
i'd say we can beef up the craft
services for the next go-around
deep blue sea made a bigger impact both
here and across the seven seas
doing 132 million dollars of business
domestically
and 297 million dollars worldwide
on a budget of about 60 million bucks
meanwhile
the most recent of our releases the meg
in 2018
is the overall breadwinner hauling in
146 million dollars in domestic receipts
and 527 million dollars across the globe
so it should be an easy swim to victory
for the megan round one
right hell yeah ah not so fast
deep blue sea's budget was about a third
the size of the meg
and it opened against some stiff
competition in the world of thrills and
chills then fancy mako sharks had to
duel against films like the blair witch
project
the sixth sense the haunting and lake
placid during its run
not to mention runaway bride in american
pie the four
most horror movie for baked goods
deep blue c is also rated r making its
performance that much more impressive
however the meg was able to top the
charts on its opening weekend
beating out fellow scary flick slender
man and a limited release of black
klansmen
plus a defeated mission impossible
fallout in that film's third week of
release
confirming that in the next mission
flick tom cruise will definitely attempt
to ride a giant shark
in the end deep blue sea gives a
compelling argument as to why it should
win the opening round
but at the end of the day the answer to
all of your questions
is money if amity island had more money
we could have had helicopters spotting
the orca and if the couple in open water
had a bigger budget they would have gone
with a more reputable scuba diving
operation
deep blue sea has proven that it's here
to win but for round one
the nod goes to the meg statham shark
punch goes up one
to nothing to nothing you know he looks
heroic and he walks fast but
he's kind of got a negative attitude
round two tomato meter slash
audience score according to round one
metrics everyone loves to see
shark movies that's been scientifically
proven in terms of tickets sold
pounds of popcorn consumed and my
unofficial stat
that folks take 90 percent more showers
than bass
after seeing a shark terrorize humans
for two hours
don't worry bathers them shark folk are
going to eventually return to re-watch
psycho and go right back to sitting in a
tub of their own filth
speaking of rotten most shark movies
tend to swim in those waters on the
tomato meter
sure jaws is certified fresh at 98 but
every other movie with jaws in the title
is rotten for funsies let's count them
down jaws 2 is at the oh so close to
fresh
spaceballs level of 59 rotten
jaws 3d is 12 rotten which doesn't sound
like anything to brag about
until you meet its sequel jaws the
revenge
kids that movie is zero percent
i don't even does that even count as
being on the tomato meter
like no one liked it come on critics
it's christmas
in the movie it's christmas time you
know what i gotta get over this
well me and a young mario van peebles
recover from this devastating news
let's see how our three shark flicks in
competition today stack up
the shallows is hey look at here
it's fresh all right 78
is a mighty fine score for any aquatic
monster tale
and it leads the school here by a wide
margin the meg has lady gaga
its way far from the shallows now as
it's a rotten 45 percent
deep lucy squarely in the middle at once
again
the legendary spaceball's numeral of 59
maybe if we had one more mako or
possibly one less thomas jane hero shot
we could have gotten afresh
don't get me wrong i love tj but every
time the guy gets out of the water it's
like he just saved atlantis that we'll
talk about that later
for now the shallows is in a commanding
lead but what did the audience score
have to say about these finned flicks
first off all of us jaws the revenge
fans finally get to celebrate we made it
to 15
on the audience side of things the
people have spoken
and while they seem fonder of our three
movies contending today
i'm not sure an actual shark could
survive in such lukewarm waters
bringing up the rear is deep blue sea at
just 39
39 that's a head scratcher let me ask
you all a question
what were you hoping for in that movie
more sharks swimming through
kitchens i have a feeling that some
folks might have been disappointed when
a certain someone stood a little too
close to the watery ledge in that movie
the mag holds steady from its tomato
meter score as it registers a 42
audience rating and now the shallows
finds itself in the dark helmet position
of 59 let's all take a moment to bask in
this anomaly
three popular shark movies that did well
at the box office
were all better liked by critics than
regular folk
huh okay for what it's worth the og jaws
is 90
on the audience score so yeah there's a
reason that's the one we still watch
every fourth of july
the music calms the dog before the
fireworks start well all the fires set
off in this round were legal and under
the guidance of a trained professional
and that happens to be how the shark in
the shallows meets its demise
we think for now until the sequel the
shallows dominates the competition
easily here and gets a w in round two
that makes one for the meg one for
gossip shark and deep blue c
is still waiting to breach the surface
round three iconic moments and now it's
time to get out on the open ocean and
toss some chum in the water
shark flicks are widely adored by
audiences for those isolated moments of
sheer terror suspense and graphic
violence that they provide
for sharks watching this vid this round
will be about the best picnic scenes in
your movies
starting with the shallows jean colette
sarah knows how to get under our skin
and get a tingle out of our spines
and that ability was on full display
from the shadows once the trailer hit
kitties i now present my college course
money shots 101.
that shadow is what got butts in seats
and it is such a cool moment because the
audience
knows more than blake does about how the
rest of her day is going to play out
job well done if you're more of a raw
survivalist movie honk don't fret
may i interest you in blake stitching
herself up or how about her ingenious
plan to test the shark's response time
so she knows exactly how long she'll
have to execute her next method of
attack
and my personal preference is to witness
someone else swim through jellyfish as
opposed to doing it myself
and wow does this shark also go through
the ringer flares
explosions stabbings you name it
the poor shark goes through a lot and it
probably just wanted an autograph from
blake lively the meg was built as a
giant summer blockbuster and director
john turtletub
knows a thing or two about pleasing
audiences on a massive scale
i could certainly watch jason statham
kick and or get chased by a humongous
shark all the live long day
but the best shot in this movie is all
those unsuspecting beachgoers getting a
surprise visit from a megalodon
my logic when swimming in the ocean is
that i'm good as long as i'm not the
slowest paddler out there
but what happens when a shark long
thought extinct shows up
and can eat all of us at the same time
panic
probably but that overhead shot is so
cool i'm all for a monstrous shark
taking on a giant squid as well but too
often the mag
missed opportunities at creating true
terror in favor of running the standard
tentpole movie playbook of
we need to create human connections they
need speaking lines more comic relief
etc
okay look you all have more than one
cool shark in the movie right
good stop there that's all we needed to
see deep blue sea
opted for a different approach giving us
a proper horror thriller
disguised as a silly shark adventure and
upon re-watching it
it's those suspenseful moments that hold
up the best oh and
this we're gonna see
who saw that coming samuel l jackson was
a legit a-lister and the biggest name of
this movie by far when it came out in
1999 and then
boom he's a goner if only the mcu could
somehow make this cannon as the how nick
fury lost his eye
another genuine surprise was good will
hunting stone skarsgard
hey he's in those comic book things too
getting his arm ripped off before an air
rescue completely trashes him
over a decade before game of thrones
deep blue sea was offing its stars and
leaving audiences shocked
ll cool j is criminally underrated for
his survivalist abilities in both this
one and
halloween h2o and in both he brings a
comedic sensibility that never
overpowers the scary tone of the flick
his cook in deep blue sea
is the shakespearean chorus that has us
at the edge of our seat
as he wades through an indoor flood
hoping to dodge a couple of super sharks
it's a thrilling sequence from start to
parrot bite
ah sorry buddy and yes thomas jane gets
a lot of emerging from a pool before
going to work as the shirt was
abercrombie mall model shots but he's
also involved as the intrepid diver in a
scene where we learned these sharks
are so smart they hunt in packs can swim
backwards
and now they take out security cameras
it's a great moment that keeps us
suspending disbelief for the rest of the
movie
all three flicks have at least a few
scenes that would keep me coming back
for more
but deep blue sea strings these together
in such a fun
thrilling occasionally silly always
terrifying and sometimes stupendously
surprising fashion
that never slows down plus sammy l i
mean come on no one saw that
coming that shark never has to pay for
another drink again
dbs gets the win and we're all tied up
as we head towards the shore
all right all right all right okay if
this is a lesson about the drinking
let's just say i've learned round four
oh the humanity
yes unfortunately when trying to enjoy
two hours of pure shark swimminess
humans find a way to intervene in these
flicks and they have tricks up their
sleeves
until that arm gets bitten off some make
us care about them others make us hate
them so much we can't wait to see them
get gobbled up by the real heroes
after all sharks are the home team in
the water but the question is
which of these movies makes us care the
most about the away team
the meg states a pretty good opening
case because us audiences
have been trained over the last 20 years
to immediately get on jason statham's
team when he shows up in anything
you're going to appeal to my better
nature and i'm going to say no
because i don't have one he had a pretty
rough go well below the surface once
upon a time as this movie opens
so when we recruit him for a new mission
in the meg we want him to succeed
we bing bing brings the most sense of
humanity and why i
should be rooting for my own species
here and as much as i'm hesitant about
too much comic relief in shark movies
rayne wilson does have some solid lines
to get giggles and break up the tension
did you guys ever watch shark week
however his overall character
motivations feel
thin and unrealistic as the threat
progresses but by that point
who cares i want to see a guy named
jonas spin kick an 80-foot shark
would i be mad if they tied the megan
with the expendables franchise
not one bit deep blue sea does a much
better job of fleshing out our human
contingent and making them the
protagonists
over the much cooler apparently smarter
aquatic foes with fins
we also get a science angle and doing
research as a solid explanation
as to how in the hell this insanity is
happening in the first place
yeah we're taking giant risks but it's
in the name of science
saffron burrows and one arm stellan make
for very believable researchers
and samuel l jackson is the perfect
choice as the moneybags who has flown in
to oversee the operation
if only there were snakes on that plane
we could have gotten a double feature
most of the heroic deeds followed the
very slippery trip prone feed of thomas
james carter blake
back in the late 90s all the cool heroes
had two first names
he's great at descending from the water
with perfect terror but he's not simply
a ken doll
he lends bravery to go along with his
brawn and the movie dialogue is at its
best when his sexual tension with
saffron's doctor character
turns into ethical debates over what
we're doing to sharks in order to
better humanity michael rappaport has
some solid lines as well
but l.l cool j steals portions of the
movie even from the sharks
with his fight-or-flight self-defense
tactics
we will begin with the perfect omelet
which is made with two eggs not three
deep blue sea has an easy time being
named the most well-rounded cast of our
contenders
meanwhile the shallows is going for the
exact opposite approach we got a surfer
we got a shark and that's pretty much it
blake lively's nancy has been through
some traumatic stuff recently
but nothing could prepare her for the
day she's about to have
and it is her performance and her family
drama to make us sympathize with nancy
over this cool looking shark similarly
this great white really does have it out
for her in particular
so much so it could care less about a
dead whale carcass
or just swimming away to meet up with
its friends this movie becomes a
personal vendetta
one has towards the other and this town
ain't big enough for the two of them
thrilling stuff
but it's tough to pull off a win in a
humanity round when the cast is limited
to blake lively and a few appearances by
scattered family members and some beach
going locals
the make has a host of players filling
out their job descriptions fine
and the shallows pulls off a remarkable
character study for the entire running
time
but it's deep blue sea that manages the
best of both worlds
confining us to a limited amount of
space very little chance to get help
but we also have enough room for a
variety of folks to contribute in a more
memorable way
it's close between the shallows and deep
blue sea and if this round was just
about birds that won me over
steven segal might triumph over the late
parrot who's very good at one-liners in
deep blue sea
but humans are essential to a good shark
movie if for nothing else
we need bait right and deep blue c has
the best smattering
they won't make us forget about brody
hooper and quinn anytime soon
but they do enough to get their second
consecutive win
and they're up two to one to one
and now it's time for the wild card
round cue the violin
you know what i'm talking about
[Music]
i don't know how to play violin but i do
know that all it takes is that first
step into the ocean
the water rises above your waist or even
just jumping in the deep end of the
community pool
for me to hear that iconic music the two
notes from jaws that send me running to
shore faster than the ice cream cart
music
if it is that violin that summons our
favorite cinematic sharks
then it's only fair that our wild card
round is simply which movie
has the coolest sharks no the mag i
didn't say which movie has the biggest
sharks but nevertheless
the prehistoric creatures emerging to
wreak havoc on modern day oceans
do have a lot going for them sheer size
has to be considered a bonus in a shark
movie
and the meg wins the way in easily
depending on which scene it is
the primary megalodon in the film is
anywhere between 60 to 80 feet
long by contrast hooper and quint argue
over whether the shark in jaws
is 20 feet or 25 feet hilariously
deep blue sea director rene harlan
insisted on the gen 2 shark measuring in
at 26 feet to topple old bruce
off the hill for the shallows the
filmmakers made the shark a female to
enhance the thrills
female sharks have scars from mating
seasons gone by
so their look is more fearsome and they
tend to be more protective and hence
aggressive
if met with a perceived threat or maybe
that shark just hated the movie green
lantern
the reveal of the shark itself is always
an exciting part of a film
and each movie took a different approach
to the reveal the meg
actually takes the longest amount of
time as the shark gave audiences
a full 30 minutes to find parking and
get snacks before it's proper reveal
renee harwin would have already left the
theater his deep blue sea is barely on
for three minutes before we meet our
finned friends
the shallows has a perfectly paced
23-minute lead up until we get to see
who we're really sharing the cove with
on this particular outing
the motivations for each shark are
somewhat murky because they don't really
get a ton of dialogue to explain
themselves
but one could reason that the megs are
simply happy to be back roaming the
earth again
as the dominant aquatic species and the
shark in the shallows
just seems really pissed doesn't want
company it's more of an introvert i
assume
it's the deep blue sea sharks i find the
most intriguing
because their genetic enhancements work
two ways in the film
it gives a credible reason as to why
scientists would want to modify them
helping us humans
while at the same time allowing them to
get smarter to pull off tricks that
liken them more to jurassic park
velociraptors
than jaws great whites that could be a
major factor in why they have so much
more screen time than their competitors
while deep blue sea can brag about over
13 and a half minutes of pure mako shark
greatness
the meg just barely gets over half of
that and the shallows
brings up the rear or dorsal fin with
this
four minutes of screen time only but
it's not quantity
it's quality and the shallows does make
it count similar in tone to jaws
the shallows makes us feel like the
shark is lurking the whole time
just out of frame it may not like to be
filmed but it's a looming presence
throughout the duration of the movie the
meg sharks take their sweet time getting
to the stage but once they do
the sheer size of them lend the film
some much needed scope and perspective
so it's great to have another super
hungry great white or an extinct
creature coming back out of retirement
but deep blue sea for all of its
silliness does the best job of
furthering the tear we already have in
our heads about
sharks they come born with teeth and
fins and size
but now they can think and react and
hunt and swim
backwards the gen modifications plus the
aggressiveness
innate and mako sharks make them the
most fearsome foes to deal with for my
money
the mag wins the battle of the bulge and
the shallow shark definitely has the
most
um detailed kill list but deep blue sea
wins the war of wave-breaking flopping
after starting out slow
deep blue sea has mounted a comeback for
the ages and has won a record third
round in a row
and thus the match are you sure it was
just three sharks
yeah oh okay
that's more like it and now those phd
graduate school sharks we'll get to take
on
jaws the revenge no we're not doing that
no
it'd be fun for true supremacy in an
upcoming episode of versus that
i'm gonna do it here in the studio after
the crew is left with the lights off
and no one will ever know the outcome
zero percent
on the tomato meter for jaws four
oh [ __ ] well it's still fun to determine
the true silver metal shark spectacle
that can stand on the stage with jaws
and say
hey people like me too we're number two
we're number two but hey that's just my
opinion and before you turn up this vid
and cancel your beach trip i'll remind
you the deep blue sea is so beloved
it has a podcast dedicated to it
fittingly titled
deep blue sea the podcast co-hosted by
our expert researcher here at rotten
tomatoes
mark hoffmeyer who genetically engineers
my brain
to retain all the fun facts he sends me
like this nugget
deep blue sea has two sequels and deep
blue c3
is actually fresh on the tomato meter
it's 71 percent
deep blue c2 well um jaws of revenge
meet your new roommate mr buttarsky zero
point
[Music]
zero so that's my opinion on the second
greatest goodness shark-ish movies
what's yours
hit me up on social media at mark ellis
live with your take
and make sure you're also following us
here at rotten tomatoes
i'll be back soon with more versus
episodes and until then farewell and
adieu
i had a drink about an hour ago and it's
probably why people who see one
[Music]
you